This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Let me be the first to wish you a happy flag day. I assume I'm the first. I'm probably the only person to wish you a happy flag day. For those of you beautiful nerds who weren't aware, flag day is June 14th. So consider this your advanced notice. If you haven't hoisted your favorite flag on your howard up to the truck
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。请允许我第一个祝你旗帜日快乐。我想我应该是第一个。我可能是唯一一个祝你旗帜日快乐的人。对于那些不知道的可爱书呆子们，旗帜日是6月14日。所以，就把这当作提前通知吧。如果你还没有把你最喜欢的旗帜升到卡车上，
or finial of your flagpole to admire its field in Canton and watch the fly end wave in the wind, well, you still have time. Anyone who's listened to 99% of us will regularly, or seen my TED Talk about flags, knows that we here at 9-9-PI, we have a thing for flags. Our stories have helped inspire people around the world to design and submit dozens of new flags to local and state governments. Flags can be beautiful things that give communities something symbolic to rally around. They can also be divisive and horrible. But since the beginning of this show, I've always liked using them as a way to talk about
或者升到旗杆顶端，去欣赏它在旗面和旗幅上的图案，看着旗尾在风中飘扬，好吧，你还有时间。任何经常收听《99% Invisible》或者看过我关于旗帜的TED演讲的人都知道，我们99PI对旗帜情有独钟。我们的故事曾激励世界各地的人们为当地和州政府设计并提交了数十面新旗帜。旗帜可以是美丽的，能给社区提供某种象征性的凝聚力。它们也可能引起分裂，令人厌恶。但自本节目开播以来，我一直喜欢用它们作为谈论
our lives as humans. And this year, we decided to get the Flag Day celebration started early and then keep the party going with two whole weeks of flag-related stories. Before we dive in, though, let's take a brief look at the history of the most popular flag in the country, which is, of course, the flag of the country. The flag of the United States of America is everywhere in this country, but the US stars and stripes haven't always held such a lofty position in popular culture. For much of American history, flags were more utilitarian, used to signal federal or military
我们人类生活的一种方式。今年，我们决定提前开启旗帜日的庆祝活动，并通过为期两周的旗帜相关故事让庆祝活动持续下去。不过，在深入探讨之前，让我们先简要回顾一下这个国家最受欢迎的旗帜的历史，当然，也就是这个国家的国旗。美利坚合众国的国旗在这个国家随处可见，但美国的星条旗在流行文化中并不总是占据如此崇高的地位。在大部分美国历史中，旗帜的功能性更强，用于标记联邦或军事
locations. It wasn't until the Civil War that everyday flag usage really got off the ground. In 1861, when Confederates attacked Fort Sumter in Charleston, Union flags began showing up all over the North. In the wake of the war, flags were increasingly incorporated into products, too, going mainstream in an unprecedented way. All of this patriotism helped lead to the establishment of an official flag day in 1916. So in my TED Talk and in past episodes, we've talked a lot about the design principles of flags, like what makes a good and bad city, state, and country flag.
地点。直到内战时期，旗帜的日常使用才真正普及开来。1861年，当邦联军队袭击查尔斯顿的萨姆特堡时，联邦旗帜开始出现在北方各地。战争结束后，旗帜也越来越多地被融入到产品中，以一种前所未有的方式进入主流。所有这些爱国主义情绪促成了1916年官方旗帜日的设立。所以，在我的TED演讲和过去的节目中，我们谈论了很多关于旗帜的设计原则，比如什么构成了好的或坏的城市、州和国家旗帜。
But for Flag Day this year, and over the next couple of episodes, we're going to talk about a few flags that are not tied directly to nation states and municipalities. They're both bigger in scope than country, but also more personal, too. So without further ado, up first is producer Joe Rosenberg. So Joe, I hear you have a really good flag story for me. Yeah, I do.
但对于今年的旗帜日，以及接下来的几期节目，我们将讨论一些并非直接与民族国家和市政当局挂钩的旗帜。它们的范围比国家更大，但也更具个人色彩。那么，废话不多说，首先登场的是制片人乔·罗森伯格。乔，我听说你有一个非常棒的旗帜故事要讲给我听。是的，确实有。
And it's a flag story, which is when I kind of came across really accidentally, I was not trying to do work for 99pi. But the work finds you. But the work finds me. It really does. But no, what this story is is a few years ago, a couple of friends and I in the Bay Area ended up checking out this little museum. Actually not that far from the 99PI offices called the Alameda Naval Air Museum. And the Alameda Naval Air Museum is how to put this. It's one of those museums that is just kind of just made with love, right?
这是一个旗帜故事，是我偶然发现的，我当时并不是在为99PI工作。但工作会找到你。工作确实找到了我。真的。但不是，这个故事是这样的：几年前，我和几个朋友在湾区逛了一家小博物馆。其实离99PI办公室不远，叫阿拉米达海军航空博物馆。阿拉米达海军航空博物馆怎么说呢？它是那种充满爱意建造的博物馆，对吧？
Yeah, it's literally my favorite kind of museum. Like a little museum devoted to one thing that you can take in all it wants. I honestly like, I love museums like this. Absolutely, and so it is a museum devoted to naval aviation history, and so it has display cases with metals and ship models and mannequins with uniforms. There's like a DVD playing in a loop in one room. And so when my friends and I visited, we were, I admit, not planning to stay long. But then, just as we were about to leave, we came across this flag. And it wasn't even on display yet, but on that day, it was kind of like in a frame, on
是的，这简直是我最喜欢的博物馆类型。就像一个小小的博物馆，只专注于一件事，你可以一次性看完。老实说，我喜欢这样的博物馆。绝对是这样，它是一个致力于海军航空历史的博物馆，里面有陈列奖章、船模和穿着制服的人体模型的展示柜。有一个房间里循环播放着DVD。所以当我和朋友们参观时，我承认，我们没打算待太久。但就在我们要离开时，我们发现了这面旗帜。它甚至还没有被展出，那天它只是被装在框里，放在
the floor, leaning against another display. But the second we saw it, we were all just like riveted. And what it was was a Japanese flag, but not your normal Japanese flag. Was it the rising sun flag with the rays coming out of it? No, that's the Japanese military flag, of course, which is a whole other story. No, this one was the regular Japanese national flag,
地板上，靠在另一个展品旁边。但我们一看到它，就被深深吸引住了。那是一面日本国旗，但不是普通的日本国旗。是那种带有光芒的旭日旗吗？不，那是日本军旗，当然，那是另一个故事了。不，这一面是普通的日本国旗，
also known as the Himalayas. This is one of the red sun in the middle in the white field. It's kind of what you'd think of as the Himari. This is one of the red sun in the middle and the white field. It's kind of what you'd think of as the flag of Japan. Exactly, except on this Himari, the white part of the flag was just covered in right. And so I did what any person would do, which is I took a picture. And here, let me show you that. Wow.
也被称为“日之丸”。就是中间有一个红太阳，背景是白色的那种。这就是你所认为的“日之丸”。就是中间有一个红太阳，背景是白色的那种。这就是你所认为的日本国旗。没错，除了在这面“日之丸”上，旗帜的白色部分被写满了字。所以我做了任何一个人都会做的事，我拍了一张照片。来，我给你看看。哇。
Okay, so all these phrases written and what looks like kanji, like kind of radiating out from the picture. And here, let me show you that. Wow. Okay, so all these phrases written and what looks like congee, like kind of radiating out from the sun, it's really lovely. Yeah, and for the listeners who can't see it, this is not like a produced flag. Right, his hand written, yeah. Exactly. Hand written calligraphy, consisting of many different messages in all different hands, written directly on the fabric. It seems as if maybe there's 50 or so people maybe more and they all have something written on it. And do you know what it says?
好的，所有的这些短语都用看起来像汉字的东西写着，从太阳向外辐射，真的很美。来，我给你看看。哇。好的，所有的这些短语都用看起来像汉字的东西写着，从太阳向外辐射，真的很美。是的，对于看不到的听众，这不是一面工业生产的旗帜。没错，是手写的，是的。完全正确。手写的书法，由许多不同的人用不同的笔迹写成，直接写在布料上。看起来可能有50个人甚至更多，他们都在上面写了东西。你知道上面写的是什么吗？
Well, yeah, because it just so happens that one of the friends I was with, she was Japanese. Oh, well that's really ridiculous. Did she know what this was? I mean, could she tell you more about this flag? No, she didn't know what it was, but she started reading the flag aloud for us. Oh, cool. So what did it say? Yeah, so along one side in the biggest characters was the name of a Japanese soldier from World War II to whom the flag presumably belonged.
嗯，知道，因为碰巧和我在一起的一个朋友是日本人。哦，那太巧了。她知道这是什么吗？我是说，她能告诉你更多关于这面旗帜的信息吗？不，她不知道这是什么，但她开始为我们大声朗读旗帜上的内容。哦，酷。那上面写了什么？是的，在一侧用最大的字符写着一名二战日本士兵的名字，这面旗帜推测就是属于他的。
And who had appeared, must have been going off to war because the messages around the sun were from people the flag bear seemed to know And to appear, it must have been going off to war, because the messages around the sun were from people the flag bear seemed to know who were giving him like this big send-off. And I'm not gonna lie, some of them wrote rather strong statements. So the most explicit was,
而且看起来，他一定是去打仗了，因为太阳周围的信息都是旗帜持有者似乎认识的人写的，而且看起来，他一定是去打仗了，因为太阳周围的信息都是旗帜持有者似乎认识的人写的，他们给了他一个盛大的送行。我不撒谎，其中一些人写了相当强烈的声明。最直白的是，
we have to kill British and Americans. But then there were also lines that were just sad, knowing what this soldier and others were about to go through. So you know, there was, we hope you will protect our country, we have the strength to win. I hope we win this year and one person also wrote like, I'm going to. But honestly, the most common phrase was just good luck. Probably that was like a quarter to a third of the messages were just good luck, or good luck this year. Wow.
我们必须杀死英国人和美国人。但也有一些句子很悲伤，考虑到这名士兵和其他人即将经历的事情。所以你知道，有“我们希望你保护我们的国家”，“我们有力量获胜”，“我希望我们今年能赢”，还有一个人写了“我会……”。但老实说，最常见的短语只是“祝你好运”。可能四分之一到三分之一的信息只是“祝你好运”或“今年祝你好运”。哇。
Yeah, and it turns out that what we were looking at was something called in Japanese, a Yosagaki Hinomaru, which means collection of writing around the sun. But in English is known as a Good Luck Flag. And it was part of a tradition very popular in Japan in the late 30s and early 40s of having people write personal messages on flags to servicemen about to go off overseas. And then they would actually carry this flag
是的，事实证明我们看到的是日语中所谓的“寄书日之丸”，意思是“围绕太阳的文字集合”。但在英语中被称为“好运旗”。这是日本30年代末和40年代初非常流行的一种传统，人们在旗帜上写下给即将前往海外服役的军人的个人信息。然后他们会把这面旗帜
folded up on their person into battle. Wow, good luck, I've never heard of. Yeah, neither did I. And so, do we know exactly how this tradition of the good luck flag merged? That is an excellent question. No. Boy Joe, I have spent years and years trying to find that out.
折叠起来，随身带入战场。哇，好运旗，我从来没听说过。是的，我也没听说过。那么，我们确切地知道这种好运旗的传统是如何产生的吗？这是一个很好的问题。不知道。天哪，乔，我花了好多年时间试图找出答案。
So this is Rex Ezek. He is a founder of an organization called Oubahn Society, which is involved with Good Luck flags, more on that in a second. And he says most scholars chart the rise of these flags to the 1930s when a lot of Japanese men were getting shipped off to fight in China. But exactly how the tradition started, no one knows. As far as I can tell, at some point, somebody got out of brush and some ink and they looked at their national flag and saw all that tempting white field
这是雷克斯·齐克。他是“奥本协会”（Obon Society）的创始人，该组织涉及好运旗，稍后会详细介绍。他说大多数学者将这些旗帜的兴起追溯到20世纪30年代，当时许多日本男人被送往中国作战。但这种传统究竟是如何开始的，没人知道。据我所知，在某个时候，有人拿起了毛笔和墨水，看着他们的国旗，看到了那片诱人的白色区域，
all around that red area. And this became a fashion or a tradition or it became instantly a thing and everybody started doing it. But one thing Rex really stressed, and I think this is very important to point out, is that most of these flags weren't nearly as militant as the one I saw in the museum. A lot of them do have messages about victory and country and being brave, but most of them were filled in with either just people's
就在红色区域周围。这成了一种时尚或传统，或者瞬间流行起来，每个人都开始这样做。但雷克斯强调了一点，我认为这一点非常重要，那就是大多数这些旗帜并不像我在博物馆看到的那样具有战斗性。很多旗帜确实有关于胜利、国家和勇敢的信息，但大多数旗帜上填写的要么只是人们的
signatures and well wishes, or else these very intimate messages from loved ones and friends and neighbors. Because you have to understand you really could write almost anything. So there's no rules and regulation or, you know, there's no guideline. And anybody might think, you know, there's no guideline. And anybody might think, this is the last time to see this man. You may not ever see him again. So it is very personal. Kiko Ziek is Rex's partner
签名和祝福，要么是来自亲人、朋友和邻居的非常亲密的信息。因为你必须明白，你真的可以写任何东西。所以没有规则和条例，或者说，没有指导方针。任何人可能都会想，这是最后一次见到这个人了。你可能再也见不到他了。所以它非常个人化。纪子·齐克是雷克斯的合伙人，
and the co-founder of Obon Society. And she says people might sometimes put poetry on the flag, others put inside jokes, priests from the local temple might write a favorite mantra. I remember one entry where it was saying something like, I'll look after the farm until you get home and I'll look after the animals,
也是奥本协会的联合创始人。她说人们有时会在旗帜上写诗，其他人写内部笑话，当地寺庙的僧侣可能会写下一句最喜欢的咒语。我记得有一个条目写着类似“我会照顾好农场直到你回家，我会照顾好动物，
until you get home. So the soldier doesn't worry about that home one, he's away. Well, it's amazing. I love that it can be anything. Absolutely. And by the way, when Rex said everybody started doing it. He meant that more or less literally We estimate that between like
直到你回家”。这样士兵在他离开时就不必担心家里的事了。嗯，太神奇了。我喜欢它可以是任何内容这一点。绝对是。顺便说一句，当雷克斯说每个人都开始这样做时，他或多或少是字面意思。我们估计在
1935 and 1945 The people of Japan created somewhere between 9 and 12 million of these flags whoa between nine and 12 million of these flags. Whoa. Yeah, and one of the reasons there's so many of them is not only did virtually every soldier get flagged, he often got multiple flags from multiple institutions on multiple occasions.
1935年到1945年之间，日本人民制作了大约900万到1200万面这样的旗帜。哇，900万到1200万面这样的旗帜。哇。是的，之所以有这么多旗帜，不仅是因为几乎每个士兵都得到了一面旗帜，他通常还会从多个机构在多个场合得到多面旗帜。
And so he might go to war, leave home with one from his parents, one from the bank where he worked, and one from his baseball team. Okay, so if there's millions of these flags, you know, what happened all of them, like where are they now? Well, most of them are gone, at least in Japan. And that's because many of those soldiers never came home. So a lot of the flags were just lost forever. And many of the flags that did make it back to Japan might have been actually deliberately gone rid of because after the war during the American occupation, certain Japanese symbols were temporarily banned. And that included the Hingamaru. And so those
所以他可能会去打仗，带着父母给的一面、工作银行给的一面、棒球队给的一面离开家。好吧，如果有数百万面这样的旗帜，你知道，它们都去哪了？嗯，大多数都不见了，至少在日本是这样。这是因为许多士兵再也没有回家。所以很多旗帜就永远丢失了。而且许多确实回到日本的旗帜可能被故意处理掉了，因为战后在美国占领期间，某些日本象征被暂时禁止了。这包括“日之丸”。所以那些
soldiers who survived who had these and went home, whether those flags would have been buried or burned or destroyed or kept, we really can't get a gauge on that. But Keko says that the result is that it was such a final ending to this tradition that most people in Japan today, if you show them one of these flags, they don't know what it is. Yeah, they've had no idea about Yosega Kinomaru and anything. But it turns out there is at least one country where you can still find a lot of good luck flags. And that's the United States. Well, tell me what that is.
幸存下来并带着这些旗帜回家的士兵，无论这些旗帜是被埋葬、烧毁、销毁还是保留，我们真的无法衡量。但纪子说，结果是这种传统以一种如此彻底的方式终结，以至于今天在日本，如果你给他们看其中一面旗帜，他们根本不知道那是什么。是的，他们对“寄书日之丸”一无所知。但事实证明，至少有一个国家你仍然可以找到很多好运旗。那就是美国。好吧，告诉我那是什么。
Well, it's kind of for an unsavory reason, but basically in World War II, a ton of American soldiers were shipped off to the Pacific and fought in battles against a ton of Japanese soldiers. And when the Americans took personal items off of dead Japanese soldiers on the battlefield, you have to understand the Americans all grew up reading books and watching movies where capturing an enemy flag was like a big deal. But unbeknownst to them, there was this tradition in Japan and so everybody on the battlefield had a flag somewhere underneath them. That's really fascinating, grimly fascinating. Yeah, and so all these US servicemen just take all these flags back to the States. But crucially, in the US, these good luck flags are not destroyed.
嗯，原因有点令人不快，但基本上在二战中，大量的美国士兵被送往太平洋，并与大量的日本士兵作战。当美国人在战场上从死去的日本士兵身上拿走个人物品时，你必须明白，美国人都是读着书、看着电影长大的，他们认为夺取敌人的旗帜是一件大事。但他们不知道的是，日本有这种传统，所以战场上的每个人身上都带着一面旗帜。这真的很迷人，令人毛骨悚然地迷人。是的，所以所有这些美国军人都把这些旗帜带回了美国。但关键的是，在美国，这些好运旗并没有被销毁。
Yeah, because they would just keep them and they'd be, you know, end up in your your grandparents' attic or basement and it's grand or whatever. Exactly. But this is where Rex and Kiko's Obon Society comes in. Because what they do is they work with families in the US who have come into possession of one of these good luck flags and often as a form of post-war healing and reconciliation, they help them return the flag to the family of the original flag bearer in Japan. Oh, so if you're like the grandson of World War II veteran like me, and find one of these flags in your grandfather's attic,
是的，因为他们会把它们留着，它们最终会出现在你祖父母的阁楼或地下室里，或者其他什么地方。完全正确。但这就是雷克斯和纪子的奥本协会发挥作用的地方。因为他们所做的是与美国那些拥有这些好运旗的家庭合作，通常作为战后治愈和和解的一种形式，他们帮助他们将旗帜归还给日本原旗帜持有者的家人。哦，所以如果你像我一样是二战老兵的孙子，在祖父的阁楼里发现了这些旗帜之一，
the Oban Society will actually find the grandchildren of the Japanese veteran that they belong to and then they will like match make and send them that flag. Exactly. And after starting out on their own more than a decade ago, Rex and Keko say that today they have a team of about 14 people that specialize in sending back these flags. And it took us I I think, four years to do the first one. And now we're doing two each week on the average. Wow, two week. I mean, so then how many have they successfully returned at this point? Well, at this point, they gave me a rough estimate of about 400 total returns.
奥本协会实际上会找到这些旗帜所属的日本老兵的孙辈，然后他们会像媒人一样把旗帜送还给他们。完全正确。在十多年前独自开始这项工作后，雷克斯和纪子说，今天他们有一个大约14人的团队，专门负责归还这些旗帜。我们花了，我想，四年时间才完成了第一面。现在我们平均每周归还两面。哇，每周两面。那么，到目前为止他们已经成功归还了多少面？嗯，目前，他们给我的粗略估计是总共归还了大约400面。
Wow. And they say their success rate is, again, roughly speaking, maybe around 50%. Their fastest find was a few days. Their longest was seven years. And then there are obviously ones that might take even longer, but they just don't know yet. So you had mentioned that the biggest thing written on the flag was the name of the flag's owner.
哇。他们说他们的成功率，再次粗略地说，大约在50%左右。他们最快的寻找记录是几天。最长的是七年。当然还有一些可能需要更长时间，但他们还不知道。所以你提到旗帜上写得最大的是旗帜主人的名字。
Is that enough to find the descendants? And turn the flag? No, not even close. There are a lot of names that are the equivalent of like John Smith. And so the only way to figure out which John Smith it belongs to is to figure out where it came from. But something that is rarely seen on these flags
这足以找到后代并归还旗帜吗？不，差得远呢。有很多名字相当于“约翰·史密斯”。所以找出它属于哪个约翰·史密斯的唯一方法是找出它来自哪里。但这些旗帜上很少见到的东西
is any geographical mention as to where it was created which drives us nuts. Yes, it's so personal, everyone knows each other. So if they write, they don't write the home dance name. And then that's what we spend so many hours trying to figure out is where did this come from? This is a fascinating mystery. So what are the techniques for figuring where they come from? This is a fascinating mystery. So what are the techniques for figuring
是关于它在哪里制作的地理信息，这让我们抓狂。是的，它太个人化了，每个人都认识彼此。所以如果他们写，他们不会写家乡的名字。这就是我们花那么多时间试图弄清楚的地方：它来自哪里？这是一个迷人的谜团。那么找出它们来自哪里的技术是什么？这是一个迷人的谜团。那么找出它们来自哪里的技术是什么？
where they come from? Well, they actually ask me not to divulge too much of their process because they don't want people who aren't experts when they find these flags to try to do this themselves. I guess that makes sense, yeah. And another thing I should add is that Rex and Kiko will never urge anyone to hand over a flag.
嗯，他们实际上要求我不要透露太多他们的流程，因为他们不希望那些不是专家的人在发现这些旗帜时试图自己做这件事。我想这说得通，是的。我还要补充一点，雷克斯和纪子永远不会催促任何人交出旗帜。
You have to come to them. And if instead you choose to keep it, they'll respect your decision no matter what it is. You know, I think that this flag return process sounds really heartfelt and great. But it's also, you know, these flags are part of military campaigns that are extremely a violent and not the best chapter in Japan's history.
你必须主动找他们。如果你选择保留它，无论你的决定是什么，他们都会尊重。你知道，我认为这种旗帜归还过程听起来真的很感人，很棒。但这也是，你知道，这些旗帜是极其暴力的军事行动的一部分，并不是日本历史上最光彩的篇章。
Are they ever used politically to, you know, harken back in a bad way to this period of time, where Japan's imperial strength was at a tight? So, I asked Rex and Kiko about that, and, you know, they really stress that when it comes to these good luck flags, they've never found that. What they've found is that the people they've worked with and returned these flags to in Japan really connect with them on a personal level because these are fastuned basically with these messages and the names of these family members. So much more than anything else, what it becomes is a memento from one single person's
它们是否曾被政治化，你知道，以一种糟糕的方式回溯到那个日本帝国实力处于顶峰的时期？所以，我问了雷克斯和纪子这个问题，你知道，他们真的强调，当谈到这些好运旗时，他们从未发现过这种情况。他们发现的是，他们合作过并归还这些旗帜的日本家庭真的在个人层面上与它们产生了联系，因为这些旗帜基本上装饰着这些信息和家庭成员的名字。比起其他任何东西，它更多地成为了一个人
life. And this is what Keko really stressed, like that was her big point. When you read everything written, it is amazing so many stories you can learn and you can feel it from this spiritual object because this is only one of the kind in the world So do they end up connecting you with someone who either found or receive the flag?
生命的纪念品。这就是纪子真正强调的，这是她最大的观点。当你阅读上面写的所有内容时，你会发现你能学到这么多故事，你可以从这个精神物品中感受到它，因为这是世界上独一无二的。那么他们最终会让你与发现或收到旗帜的人联系吗？
They did My name is Koishi Noriko Noriko Koishi Nester So I got a hold of Noriko Koishi via translator just outside the town of Kobe in Kiyoko prefecture Noriko is in her mid 80s, which means she really grew up during the war. And back then, it was just her and her mother and her father, Noriko Yomaguchi. And Noriko Yomaguchi was an executive at a local ceramics factory. But Noriko says that her memories of him are very faint. Her dad was a busy salaryman who worked very long hours, so by the time she wakes up, he will be already gone to work
他们确实这样做了。我的名字是小石纪子。我通过翻译在兵库县神户市外联系到了小石纪子。纪子已经80多岁了，这意味着她确实是在战争期间长大的。那时，只有她和她的母亲，以及她的父亲，山口纪康。山口纪康是当地一家陶瓷工厂的高管。但纪子说她对他的记忆非常模糊。她的父亲是一个忙碌的工薪族，工作时间很长，所以当她醒来时，他已经去上班了，
and then come back after she fell asleep. Obviously, because we were, there is not much of a memory aside from that. So instead, what she actually remembers most vividly about her father is him leaving for the war. Because when she was about nine years old, Noryatsu was drafted to go fight in the Philippines. And that was in 1944. And Noriko says he did not want to go. Much more on this than all of the time.
然后等她睡着后才回来。显然，因为我们，除了那个之外没有太多的记忆。所以相反，她实际上对父亲最生动的记忆是他去打仗。因为当她大约九岁时，纪康被征召去菲律宾作战。那是1944年。纪子说他不想去。关于这一点，比所有时间都多。
Because, of course, by 1944, the whole country of Japan sort of knew that there won't be a victory, but obviously nobody is going to say that out loud. But the general thinking was that getting drafted at this point was basically a death sentence. So Nareko actually remembers that her mother began kind of frantically suggesting that they all maybe run away to the countryside so that her father could dodge the draft. I'm starting the phase. Saying the consequences of you doing that will result to they won't be able to get any food from the government nor record won't be able to go to school. It will be a disgrace to the family and she
因为当然，到1944年，整个日本都知道不会有胜利，但显然没有人会大声说出来。但普遍的想法是，在这一点上被征召基本上就是死刑。所以纪子实际上记得她的母亲开始有点疯狂地建议他们全家也许逃到乡下，这样她的父亲就可以逃避征兵。我开始那个阶段。说你那样做的后果将导致他们无法从政府那里得到任何食物，纪子将无法上学。这对家庭来说将是一种耻辱，她
remembers that that scene where her grandfather hit her mother. That is an incredibly intense thing to remember. Yeah, and also just remembering the way they were kind of locked into this reality, which was that he had to go. And so her other vivid memory from that time is this kind of distilled image of the last moment she saw him. So she sent him off at the train station, and her dad was sort of on the deck of the train and he was wearing this white glove and living at her until the train made that curve and she couldn't see him anymore
记得她祖父打她母亲的那一幕。那是一个令人难以置信的强烈记忆。是的，也记得他们被困在这种现实中的方式，那就是他必须去。所以她那个时期另一个生动的记忆是她最后一次见到他的那种提炼出来的画面。她在火车站送他，她的父亲在火车的甲板上，他戴着这副白手套，一直向她挥手，直到火车转弯，她再也看不见他了，
and to this day she still remembers that white glove in the distance, waving at her. And then he just never came home. And when Noriko was already 12 or 13, so well after the war ended, her mother finally received a letter in the mail from the government just saying, we can confirm he died in the war. And that's it. And they never received any remains.
直到今天，她仍然记得远处的那个白手套，向她挥手。然后他就再也没有回家。当纪子已经12或13岁时，也就是战争结束后很久，她的母亲终于收到了政府寄来的一封信，上面写着：我们确认他在战争中阵亡了。就是这样。他们从未收到任何遗骸。
And so, since you're telling his story during this other story of good flock flags, presumably he was given a good flock flag to the day know anything about that the family. Yeah, so Nrico says that there had in fact been a sending off ceremony for her father, which she had attended, in which she put her hand print actually on a good luck flag that he took with him. Yeah, but when I asked her if that ceremony meant anything to her at the time, or if she yearned to see the flag this was the ninth, tenth flag. So it became sort of a monotonous routine. So the answer is no, she did not even think for a second
所以，既然你在讲述好运旗的故事时讲述了他的故事，推测他被给了一面好运旗，家人知道这件事吗？是的，所以纪子说，事实上确实为她的父亲举行了送行仪式，她参加了，她实际上在好运旗上按下了她的手印，他带着它走了。是的，但当我问她那个仪式在当时对她是否有意义，或者她是否渴望看到这面旗帜时，这是第九、第十面旗帜。所以它变成了一种单调的例行公事。所以答案是，不，她甚至没有想过一秒钟
of her throes flags. Well, I mean, it gets it makes sense when we talk about them being made over and over again for various people like you do it and You know life moves on even if you face tragedy Exactly So what I would like to hear at this point is that Noriko's good luck flag was found and we have her little handprint on it well kind of a flag was found and
关于她的那些旗帜。嗯，我的意思是，当我们谈论它们被反复为不同的人制作时，这说得通，你做了它，你知道生活继续前进，即使你面临悲剧。完全正确。所以此时我想听到的是，纪子的好运旗被找到了，我们有她的小手印在上面。好吧，某种旗帜被找到了，
Who first found it and how is itself a bit of mystery? Well, I actually didn't know anything. I really didn't know anything about his war experience. So this is Dion blazing. I got a hold of her where she lives in Florida and the person she is talking about here is her late uncle Neil Horde. Otherwise, none of this Uncle Bud. Uncle Bud, okay. Yeah, and Dion, as a child growing up, spent vacations with her uncle and in Michigan. And the two of them, they didn't have children, so they go to Doloverous, and they had a house that was on a lake, and he always had a boat ready for us.
谁先发现的以及它是如何发现的本身就是一个谜。嗯，我实际上什么都不知道。我真的对他战争的经历一无所知。这是迪翁·布雷辛。我在佛罗里达她住的地方联系到了她，她在这里谈论的人是她已故的叔叔尼尔·霍德。否则，没人知道这个“巴德叔叔”。巴德叔叔，好的。是的，迪翁小时候在密歇根州和叔叔一起度过假期。他们俩没有孩子，所以他们去多洛弗勒斯，他们在湖边有一栋房子，他总是为我们准备好船。
I mean, he just wanted to play. But she also knew that he had served in the war in the Pacific. And although she saw a lot of photos of him in uniform, what actually went on in the war was kind of like a no-go area. So we have pictures of him in his uniform, is pictures of him before he left, we have pictures of him as they were training to leave,
我的意思是，他只是想玩。但她也知道他在太平洋战争中服役。虽然她看到了很多他穿制服的照片，但战争中实际发生了什么就像是一个禁区。所以我们有他穿制服的照片，有他离开前的照片，有他们训练准备离开时的照片，
you know, Yadda, so I knew from pictures something about it, but they never talked about it. This was not a discussion that you had at the house. The only thing Deon ever really learned, and even this was much later, was that Uncle Bud had actually been found very badly wounded and in a coma on a battlefield before returning to the States. And that battlefield had been in the Philippines. So fast forward to the year 2016, when Uncle Blood at the age of 95 passes away.
你知道，等等，所以我从照片中知道了一些关于它的事情，但他们从不谈论它。这不是你在家里会进行的讨论。迪翁后来学到的唯一一件事，即使是这也要晚得多，是巴德叔叔在回到美国之前，实际上是在战场上被发现受了重伤并陷入昏迷。那个战场是在菲律宾。所以快进到2016年，巴德叔叔在95岁时去世了。
And Dion and the other family members are clearing out his things, including this crate of just like old stuff that no one else wants. So I opened it up and I pulled out this box. And when she got back home and opened the box, there was this white bag with this silk material in it. And I was like, what the heck is this? And it outcomes the flag. And although she didn't know it at the time,
迪翁和其他家庭成员在清理他的东西，包括这个装满没人要的旧东西的板条箱。所以我打开它，拿出了这个盒子。当她回到家打开盒子时，里面有一个白色的袋子，装着这种丝绸材料。我当时想，这到底是什么鬼东西？然后旗帜就出来了。虽然她当时不知道，
what it was was a good luck flag. And here, let me show it to you. Wow, it's like pristine. It's like not faded at all. Yeah, exactly. It's like time travel. So as you've set this up, I'm expecting this to be Noriko's father's flag, but there's no handprint on it. Well, aha, here is where there is a tiny little twist in the story, because Dion, after doing some googling,
它是一面好运旗。来，我给你看看。哇，它看起来完好无损。它看起来一点都没有褪色。是的，完全正确。这就像时间旅行。正如你所设定的，我以为这会是纪子父亲的旗帜，但上面没有手印。嗯，啊哈，这里故事有一个小小的转折，因为迪翁在谷歌搜索了一些东西后，
figured out what kind of flag it was. She found Oban's Society, and she decided that she wanted to find the flag's original family. And so she sent it to Rex and Keko, and they started analyzing. And so looking back at the flag, do you see the characters along the right hand edge, the second to the right?
弄清楚了这是什么旗帜。她找到了奥本协会，她决定她想找到这面旗帜最初的家庭。所以她把它寄给了雷克斯和纪子，他们开始分析。所以回顾这面旗帜，你看到右侧边缘的字符了吗，右边第二个？
Yes. So that is the name of a ceramics factory in the town of Kobe, in Hiyoga Prefecture, Japan. So this is from his factory where he worked. This is like a flag from his co-worker sending him off. Yeah, he had a second flag and this was it. So Akka telling Dion, you know, hey, it could take years. Rex and Kiko called her like two months later.
是的。那是日本兵库县神户市一家陶瓷工厂的名字。所以这是来自他工作的工厂。这就像是他的同事送他离开的旗帜。是的，他有第二面旗帜，这就是那面。所以阿卡告诉迪翁，你知道，嘿，这可能需要几年时间。雷克斯和纪子大约两个月后给她打了电话。
And said, we found the family. And I was like, you're kidding. And they said, no, we're not. And it was at this point that Dion says she did start to have some trepidation about this whole process. Because having already handed over the flag to Obone Society, there were no take back.
说，我们找到了这个家庭。我当时想，你在开玩笑吧。他们说，不，我们没有。就在这时，迪翁说她确实开始对整个过程感到有些不安。因为已经把旗帜交给了奥本协会，没有退货。
She couldn't ask for it back. And so now that they've found the family, Deon says this thing she had said in motion suddenly got much more real, and she was getting kind of nervous. And part of the reason was, I really wasn't sure what the rest of my family would think about this, right?
她不能要求把它要回来。所以现在他们找到了这个家庭，迪翁说她启动的这件事突然变得真实多了，她开始感到有点紧张。部分原因是，我真的不确定我的家人会怎么想，对吧？
I was making this executive decision. Does that because you didn't tell anyone else in your family or did you check with them? What was the conversation? No, I didn't check with them. I didn't check with them. Why not? Why not? Because I was afraid they'd say no.
我做出了这个行政决定。那是因为你没有告诉家里其他人，还是你和他们核实过？谈话内容是什么？不，我没有和他们核实。我没有和他们核实。为什么不呢？为什么不呢？因为我怕他们会说不。
This is another thing, Rex and Kiko run into sometimes, people feel that the flag is more a memento of their loved one now than of this person back in Japan and they want to keep it. But Deon said that wasn't so much her concern as it was that she thought her family might get upset about the idea of sending this flag back to the country that had caused Uncle Bud just so much pain and suffering. But my thing is I don't believe that individual soldiers should be held accountable for what their governments did or what they did on behalf of their governments. So I just decided I wasn't going to have that discussion. That's what it was. I just figured I
这是雷克斯和纪子有时会遇到的另一件事，人们觉得这面旗帜现在更多是他们所爱之人的纪念品，而不是日本那个人的，他们想保留它。但迪翁说，这与其说是她的担忧，不如说是她认为她的家人可能会因为把这面旗帜送回那个给巴德叔叔造成如此多痛苦和折磨的国家而感到不安。但我的想法是，我不认为个别士兵应该为他们的政府所做的事情，或者他们代表政府所做的事情负责。所以我只是决定我不打算进行那种讨论。就是这样。我只是觉得我
would do it because I thought it needed to go back to that family. You know, and if I got in trouble for it, I got in trouble for it. And so off the flag went after 75 years to Noriko Kouichi. And although Oban society did contact her ahead of time to let her know that this was happening, once again, just like her father's death notice, it just came in the mail. A Yumi Asamiya-mochi-kuri-mochi. The post person brought it to her in the envelope. So nobody actually protected it to her. And her mother passed away 20 years ago. She's a only child. So she had no choice but to open it by herself.
会这样做，因为我认为它需要回到那个家庭。你知道，如果我因此惹上麻烦，那就惹上麻烦吧。于是，75年后，这面旗帜被送回给了小石纪子。虽然奥本协会确实提前联系了她，让她知道这件事正在发生，但再一次，就像她父亲的死亡通知一样，它只是通过邮件寄来的。邮递员把它装在信封里带给了她。所以没有人亲自把它交给她。她的母亲20年前去世了。她是独生女。所以她别无选择，只能自己打开它。
She worried if her dad's blood would be on it or is it ripped or is it soiled. So there was happy and worried at the same time. And so when she did open it and it was just in this perfect condition, she said she was just so so thankful. So Nureka wrote Dionne a thank you letter and the letter honestly just describes in this incredible way what she and Riko did next and her thoughts and feelings far better than I could. And so I'll just let Dion read the letter, which I've abridged and edited a bit, but here it is.
她担心她父亲的血是否会在上面，或者它是否被撕裂或弄脏了。所以她当时既高兴又担心。当她打开它，发现它处于这种完美状态时，她说她真的非常非常感激。所以纪子给迪翁写了一封感谢信，这封信老实说以一种不可思议的方式描述了她和纪子接下来所做的事情，以及她的想法和感受，比我能描述的要好得多。所以我只是让迪翁读这封信，我删减和编辑了一点，但内容如下。
Dear Mrs. Dion emblazing, I have unexpectedly received the flag of my father by virtue of your thoughtful offer in support of Obun Society. I felt this proved his strong desire to come home because his flag returned home just before his birthday on October 26th. However, my mother and his brothers as well as his parents all passed away. Now I'm the only person who keeps my father's memory. I think it was very lucky your uncle found my father's flag in the middle of war and brought it to Michigan. I truly appreciate he preserved it very carefully, even though it must have been carried through the battlefield. I look at my father having returned home and wonder if he finds me acceptable to be his daughter. On the night his flag returned,
亲爱的迪翁·布雷辛女士，我意外地收到了我父亲的旗帜，这得益于您支持奥本协会的体贴提议。我觉得这证明了他回家的强烈愿望，因为他的旗帜在10月26日他生日之前回到了家。然而，我的母亲和他的兄弟们以及他的父母都去世了。现在我是唯一一个保留我父亲记忆的人。我认为你叔叔在战争中发现我父亲的旗帜并把它带到密歇根州是非常幸运的。我真心感谢他非常小心地保存了它，尽管它一定是被带过了战场。我看着我父亲回到家，想知道他是否觉得我作为他的女儿是可以接受的。在他旗帜回来的那天晚上，
almost as if my father rubbed his cheek against my cheek after a long time. I held the flag in the chest and fell into a shallot sleep trying to control my emotion. Such reunion with my father would never have happened without your uncle's thoughtfulness and your arrangement. I announced the return of the flag to my late mother at the family grave. With your generous help, my father finally can rest in peace after 75 years long journey. Under COVID pandemic, please take care of yourself with sincere gratitude. Noriko Koishi. Wow, that's remarkable. That letter, I mean, it just shows what a fantastic person Noreka is that she has the generosity of the spirit to thank her uncle for preserving it and getting it back to her somehow, even though, you know.
几乎就像我父亲在很长一段时间后用脸颊蹭了蹭我的脸颊。我把旗帜抱在胸前，试图控制自己的情绪，陷入了浅睡。如果没有你叔叔的体贴和你的安排，这种与父亲的重逢永远不会发生。我在家族墓地向我已故的母亲宣布了旗帜的归还。有了你慷慨的帮助，我父亲终于在75年的漫长旅程后可以安息了。在新冠疫情期间，请保重，衷心感谢。小石纪子。哇，这太了不起了。那封信，我的意思是，它只是展示了纪子是一个多么了不起的人，她有那种慷慨的精神去感谢她叔叔保存它并以某种方式把它还给她，尽管，你知道。
They fought on opposite sides of this war. Even they fought it, exactly, exactly. That's just a great thing. And I think she got back so much more in that letter than she would ever had keeping that flag. You know, Deon said more or less the same thing. And not only was Nareko incredibly gracious, it turns out, so was Dion's own family.
他们在战争的对立面作战。即使他们作战，完全正确，完全正确。那真是一件伟大的事情。而且我认为她在信中得到的比她保留那面旗帜所能得到的要多得多。你知道，迪翁说得差不多也是这样。不仅纪子非常优雅，事实证明，迪翁自己的家人也是如此。
Because when she finally did tell them what she had done, she says they weren't angry at all. Not with Dion and not with the Rico's father. They were just happy to see his flag return home. Coming up, finding the perfect flag for a whole continent after this. Antarctica is a strange and wonderful place. It doesn't have a permanent human population, but it's the temporary home to a codery of research scientists and weird tourists.
因为当她最终告诉他们她所做的事情时，她说他们一点也不生气。不是对迪翁，也不是对纪子的父亲。他们只是很高兴看到他的旗帜回到家。接下来，在这一段之后，为整个大陆寻找完美的旗帜。南极洲是一个奇怪而美妙的地方。它没有永久的人类居住，但它是研究科学家和怪异游客的临时家园。
The thing came a couple of times. It's this huge landmass that doesn't have an independent government, which makes its history of flags particularly interesting. And 99pi's own cold set is here to tell us about it. So at any given time, there are tons of different flags circling the South Pole. In part because of Antarctica's unique political history. So over the centuries, various countries have made a range of claims to the specific regions, or even the whole continent.
这东西来过几次。这是一个巨大的陆地，没有独立的政府，这使得它的旗帜历史特别有趣。99PI自己的科尔·塞特在这里告诉我们关于它的事情。所以，在任何时候，都有大量的不同旗帜在南极点周围盘旋。部分原因是南极洲独特的政治历史。所以几个世纪以来，各国对特定地区，甚至整个大陆都提出了各种主张。
But this place is extremely cold and remote, and it doesn't really lend itself to full-time imperialist occupation So instead people rotate in and out and they stay there for a while and then they return to their home countries That makes sense, but they would return to their home country because it is truly inhospitable I mean so given that there are visitors that come from all over I would imagine that if you walked around different bases and research facilities that you would see different countries flags all over the place. Absolutely.
但这个地方极其寒冷和偏远，它并不真正适合全职的帝国主义占领。所以人们轮流进出，他们在那里待上一段时间，然后回到他们的祖国。这说得通，但他们会回到他们的祖国，因为那里确实不适合居住。我的意思是，考虑到来自世界各地的游客，我想如果你在不同的基地和研究设施周围走动，你会看到不同国家的旗帜到处都是。绝对是。
There are tons of flags for all these different nations, and in some cases, there are even territory specific designs created to make political claims to specific areas seem more official. So explain that to me more. So flags that are designed by specific countries that are trying to gain or maintain a foothold, like they make a kind of variation of their flag that's Antarctica-like. Exactly. Like they take their flag and then they, you know, turn it into a hybrid and they add some
所有这些不同的国家都有大量的旗帜，在某些情况下，甚至有特定领土的设计，旨在使对特定地区的政治主张看起来更正式。所以再多给我解释一下。所以由试图获得或维持立足点的特定国家设计的旗帜，就像他们制作了一种类似于南极洲的旗帜变体。完全正确。就像他们拿走他们的旗帜，然后，你知道，把它变成一个混合体，他们添加了一些
elements to make it really clear. Like this is our flag, but this is also our flag specifically for Antarctica or for the section of it. I see. I see. Yeah. But this is also our flag specifically for Antarctica or for the section of it. And I see. Yeah, to confuse things even more, some of these historically claimed areas overlap or have been contested. So the result is you've got this perfusion of flags reflecting the continent's history
元素来使它非常清晰。就像这是我们的旗帜，但这也是我们专门为南极洲或其部分地区设计的旗帜。我明白了。我明白了。是的。为了让事情更令人困惑，其中一些历史上声称的区域重叠或一直存在争议。所以结果是，你拥有这种反映大陆历史的旗帜的涌入。
and all these layers of political complexity and dispute. I mean, that all sounds really messy that there would be these official national flags and also these weird regional flags tied to different countries. But I know that I've seen an actual flag of Antarctica. At some point, that's basically the shape of the continent and this sort of like an icy white shape the continent. And it's like in this field of dark, watery blue. Like I know that I've seen that.
还有所有这些政治复杂性和争议的层面。我的意思是，这听起来真的很混乱，既有官方的国旗，又有与不同国家挂钩的奇怪的地区旗帜。但我知道我见过一面真正的南极洲旗帜。在某种程度上，它基本上就是大陆的形状，一种冰冷的白色形状。它就像是在一片深邃、水蓝色的背景中。我知道我见过那个。
Yes, you definitely have. There are actually two designs along those lines. And neither of them is official, but they both have been used in a variety of contexts. So the older one is really just the emblem of the Antarctic Treaty, which is an international agreement signed by a dozen nations back in the 50s.
是的，你肯定见过。实际上有两种符合这种描述的设计。它们都不是官方的，但都在各种场合中使用过。较旧的那一面实际上只是《南极条约》的标志，这是一项由十几个国家在50年代签署的国际协议。
And it's a lot like the United Nations flag with land shown in white against this field of blue. Oh, I see the resemblance. Okay, so the UN flag is kind of a globe from, you see it from the North Pole axis and you see like the whole globe and the latitude and longitude lines and then it has those branches,
它很像联合国旗帜，以蓝色为背景，白色显示陆地。哦，我看到了相似之处。好吧，联合国旗帜有点像从北极轴线看到的地球仪，你可以看到整个地球以及经纬线，然后它有那些树枝，
I don't know what those things are. Those like Caesar's crown branches wrapping around it. Around it. And the Antarctic flag that is modeled after this one is basically the continent of Antarctica, and you see the latitudes and longitude lines. And it's, it looks pretty cool, but you can totally see that it was based off of the UN flag and the treaty. Yeah, absolutely.
我不知道那些是什么。就像凯撒的皇冠树枝环绕着它。环绕着它。而以这个为蓝本的南极旗帜基本上就是南极大陆，你可以看到经纬线。它看起来很酷，但你完全可以看出它是基于联合国旗帜和条约设计的。是的，绝对是。
And that's, you know, because the UN was really integral to establishing this treaty, which in turn established Antarctica as this peaceful and shared place for exploration and discovery rather than a territory to be conquered and divided up. And so initially, the treaty included countries that already had research stations and then over time other UN members were invited to join too. What about those countries that wanted bits and pieces out of themselves? And we did a whole story about a Russian research station that had a bustle in it. So like, what did the treaty address that?
你知道，这是因为联合国在建立这项条约方面确实不可或缺，该条约反过来将南极洲确立为一个和平与共享的探索和发现之地，而不是一个被征服和瓜分的领土。因此，最初该条约包括了已经拥有研究站的国家，后来其他联合国成员国也被邀请加入。那么那些想要分一杯羹的国家呢？我们做过一个关于俄罗斯研究站里有小酒馆的故事。那么，条约是如何处理这个问题的呢？
Well, so no, it didn't. It kind of scorted the issue. And what it did was it put a stop to new claims. It said, okay, there are gonna be no new territorial claims, but it didn't really resolve the existing ones. And in the midst of all this, this emblem that was made in association with the treaty became a kind of de facto flag for it to start with,
嗯，没有，它没有处理。它有点回避了这个问题。它所做的是阻止了新的主张。它说，好吧，不会有新的领土主张，但它并没有真正解决现有的主张。在这一切之中，这个与条约相关的标志开始成为它事实上的旗帜，
not technically official, but kind of a baseline design to work with the absence of something more official. Right. I mean, it still sort of confuses the what would make an official flag event, or to begin with, but you'd mentioned there was a second flag that was like this one to what, which one is that one? Right. So this is kind of an evolution of the first one where in the 1990s, this Vexlaw just named Graham Bartrom simplified the emblem. He essentially removed those lines and curves that represented latitude and longitude and created this more streamlined version, which is really just an outline of the continent in white surrounded by blue. So, this is the one I've seen more, like this the one I'm familiar with.
虽然在技术上不是官方的，但在缺乏更正式的东西时，它算是一个基准设计。没错。我的意思是，它仍然让人困惑，到底什么才能成为一面官方旗帜，但你提到还有第二面旗帜像这一面，是哪一面？对，这算是第一面的演变，在20世纪90年代，这位名叫格雷厄姆·巴特罗姆的旗帜学家简化了这个标志。他基本上删除了代表经纬度的线条和曲线，创造了这个更流线型的版本，实际上只是白色的大陆轮廓，周围是蓝色。所以，这是我见过更多的那一面，也是我熟悉的那一面。
And it looks like a really lovely flag. It's like it's the shape of the continent. It represents a thing. I kind of like map flags. I tend to like a little more abstract than this one, but I do like ones that have some sort of geographical basis in them. So why isn't this one the official flag?
它看起来是一面非常可爱的旗帜。它就是大陆的形状。它代表了一个事物。我有点喜欢地图旗帜。我倾向于喜欢比这个更抽象一点的，但我确实喜欢那些带有某种地理基础的旗帜。那么为什么这一面不是官方旗帜呢？
Well, so that you kind of already hinted at this, but it's kind of more specific than a lot of map flags, and that specificity is part of the problem, because this geographic outline is complex, and it's also not totally accurate, because Antarctica's shape continues to shift as it's icy edges melt. And so as a flag, it's not really future proof because of this literally changing landscape. And you know, this isn't just a nitpicky critique because climate change poses really serious threats to the continent. Right. So like it's a bigger problem than a flag design, but it's like it's pointing out a real practical issue that you cannot rely on an aerial photograph of this piece of geography for your permanent symbolism
嗯，你已经暗示了这一点，但它比许多地图旗帜更具体，而这种具体性正是问题的一部分，因为这个地理轮廓很复杂，而且也不完全准确，因为随着冰缘融化，南极洲的形状在不断变化。所以作为一面旗帜，它并不是真正经得起未来考验的，因为这片景观在字面上是不断变化的。你知道，这不仅仅是一个吹毛求疵的批评，因为气候变化对这片大陆构成了非常严重的威胁。没错。所以这比旗帜设计本身是一个更大的问题，但它指出了一个实际问题，即你不能依赖这张地理照片作为你的永久象征，
if it's going to constantly change, especially with Antarctica, because especially because the icy edges make it so that it really does constantly change. I mean, Ernest Shackleton learned this, the hard one. So is there any other designs that are not relying on the outward geography of the con? Yeah, so there's this one flag that's fairly recent and somewhat official and it might have been in the best looking flag so far and it's really different from these other two. It was made by the founder of a non-political group called True South. And here it is.
如果它会不断变化，尤其是南极洲，因为冰缘使得它确实在不断变化。我的意思是，欧内斯特·沙克尔顿对此深有体会。那么还有其他不依赖于大陆外部地理的设计吗？是的，有一面旗帜相当新，而且在某种程度上是官方的，它可能是目前为止最好看的旗帜，而且它与另外两面旗帜非常不同。它是由一个名为“真实南方”的非政治组织的创始人制作的。这就是它。
Oh, this is beautiful. It's really simple and elegant. There's a bar of blue on the top and a bar of white at the bottom. And then there's kind of like a diamond shape and it's sort of like a pyramid, but you can see it from both dimensions. Like kind of like the thing that is above your head when you play the Sims, you know,
哦，这太美了。它非常简单优雅。顶部有一条蓝色条纹，底部有一条白色条纹。然后有一个类似钻石的形状，它有点像金字塔，但你可以从两个维度看到它。就像你在玩《模拟人生》时头顶上的那个东西，你知道，
that sort of green sort of crystal thing. But so the top of the diamond is white, and that contrasts the bar of a blue on the top, and then the bottom of the diamond is blue, and it contrasts the bar of white at the bottom. I mean, it's really, really lovely. I like it a lot. I do too, and it's, you know, it gets so far with just these two colors and the simple geometry. But what I like most about it is that it was actually made in Antarctica. Yeah, so it's called the true South Flag
那种绿色的水晶东西。但是钻石的顶部是白色的，它与顶部的蓝色条纹形成对比，而钻石的底部是蓝色的，它与底部的白色条纹形成对比。我的意思是，它真的非常可爱。我很喜欢它。我也喜欢，而且你知道，它仅用这两种颜色和简单的几何形状就达到了这种效果。但我最喜欢它的一点是，它实际上是在南极洲制作的。是的，所以它被称为“真实南方旗帜”，
and it was created by this guy named Evan Townsend who at the time was living and working at McMurdo which is the largest station on the continent. And while he was there, you can imagine, like, there's not a lot to do. You know, he sat down, thought up and sketched out this design. And then he started literally gathering up scraps of canvas and tents and actually made his own physical prototype of it. Oh, I love it. It really is. You have some time on your hands. That's what you do. Long nights. Very long nights.
它是由一个名叫埃文·汤森德的人创造的，当时他住在并工作在麦克默多站，这是大陆上最大的研究站。当他在那里时，你可以想象，没什么事可做。你知道，他坐下来，构思并草拟了这个设计。然后他开始字面上收集帆布和帐篷的碎片，并亲自制作了他的物理原型。哦，我喜欢它。它确实如此。你有空闲时间。这就是你所做的。漫长的夜晚。非常漫长的夜晚。
is you have some time on your hands. So that's what you do. Long nights very long nights. But so aside from following good vuxilogical principles around simplistic and clarity, does the diamond have deeper meaning or symbolism? It does. And honestly, I would be doing it in injustice if I tried to paraphrase this.
你有空闲时间。所以这就是你所做的。漫长的夜晚，非常漫长的夜晚。但是，除了遵循关于简洁和清晰的良好旗帜学原则外，这个钻石有更深层的含义或象征意义吗？有的。老实说，如果我试图转述这一点，那将是对它的不公。
So I'm just going to give you this excerpt from Townsend to read about the design. Okay, so here's a quote. Horizontal stripes of navy and white represent the long days and nights at Antarctica's extreme latitude. In the center, a lone white peak erupts from a field of snow and ice, echoing those of the birds, mountains, and pressure ridges that define the antartic horizon. The long shadow of cast forms an unmistakable shape of a compass arrow pointed south, in homage to the continent's legacy of exploration.
所以我只是给你读一段汤森德关于这个设计的摘录。好的，这是一段引文。“海军蓝和白色的水平条纹代表了南极极端纬度下的漫长昼夜。在中心，一座孤独的白色山峰从雪和冰原中喷薄而出，呼应了定义南极地平线的冰山、山脉和压力脊。投下的长影形成了不可错认的指南针箭头形状，指向南方，以向这片大陆的探索遗产致敬。”
Together, the two center shapes created diamond, symbolizing the hope that an article will continue to be a center of peace, discovery, and cooperation for generations to come. That's great. Really compelling. Evocative symbolism is clearly thought out. The core of it is really powerful too. This is not a nation or collection of territories. This is a peaceful and distinctive place that we share and protect and work on together.
“两个中心形状共同创造了一个钻石，象征着南极洲将继续成为子孙后代和平、发现和合作中心的希望。”太棒了。真的很有说服力。令人回味的象征意义显然经过深思熟虑。它的核心也非常强大。这不是一个国家或领土集合。这是一个我们共享、保护并共同努力的和平而独特的地方。
Exactly. I love all of that. I also love his attention to detail. He includes these really subtle elements too. Like he went out of his way to make sure that the blue he was using on the flag was different from any other blue found on any other national flag in the world. Huh. So like no one could have greater claim for a flag. That's so good. Oh, okay. That's so good. So I guess the true test of a flag like this is like are people using it?
没错。我喜欢所有这些。我也喜欢他对细节的关注。他还包括了这些非常微妙的元素。比如他特意确保他在旗帜上使用的蓝色与世界上任何其他国旗上的蓝色都不同。哈。所以没有人能对这面旗帜有更大的主张。太好了。哦，好的。太好了。所以我猜像这样一面旗帜的真正考验是，人们在使用它吗？
Like do you see it around stations? Yes, you do. It was actually really quickly adopted by various Antarctic nonprofits and expedition teams. So it's already been flown in camps and research stations and by fans around the world who've never even been to Antarctica. And it remains to be seen whether this will become fully official,
比如你在研究站周围看到它了吗？是的，你看到了。它实际上很快就被各种南极非营利组织和探险队采用了。所以它已经在营地、研究站以及世界各地从未去过南极洲的粉丝中飘扬了。它是否会完全成为官方旗帜还有待观察，
but it's gaining traction. And it's also non-commercial, it's a free to use creation, so anybody can adopt it or fly it, or even change it if they want to. I mean, that's the thing I love about Flux. The whole point is that we all own them and nobody owns them. Exactly. That's the greatest thing about them. So if it all goes well, what would it take to make it official?
但它正在获得动力。而且它也是非商业性的，是一个免费使用的创作，所以任何人都可以采用它或悬挂它，甚至如果他们愿意，还可以修改它。我的意思是，这就是我喜欢旗帜学的地方。重点是我们都拥有它们，而没有人拥有它们。没错。这是它们最棒的地方。所以如果一切顺利，要使它成为官方旗帜需要什么？
Like, I'm just confused as to what would make things in Antarctica real. Like, I feel like that's a ball this land. You know, it is a very straight place. But according to Townsend, either the Antarctic Treaty system or the UN could theoretically just decide to adopt it, which might actually happen if it gets enough of this kind of grassroots support that it's been building, right? And what about the old claims to territories made by different countries? Like won't some nations take some issue with the use of a single flag for a whole continent?
比如，我只是困惑什么能让南极洲的事情变得真实。我觉得那是一片无主之地。你知道，这是一个非常奇怪的地方。但根据汤森德的说法，南极条约体系或联合国理论上都可以决定采用它，如果它获得了它一直在建立的那种草根支持，这实际上可能会发生，对吧？那么不同国家对领土的旧主张呢？比如，难道不会有一些国家对整个大陆使用一面旗帜有异议吗？
Well, maybe, but towns and maintains that this design is not meant to be divisive or to settle any of these kind of legacy political disputes. It's supposed to be something that people who want to protect the continent can rally behind, regardless of different vested interests that they might have or that their countries might have. So, while it's made for Antarctica, he hopes that people will just continue to fly it around the world and see it as this unifying icon. Something that helps everybody become more interested and invested in the conservation of this really unique place. Well, this is such a good story and the result is a really good
嗯，也许吧，但汤森德坚持认为这个设计并不是为了制造分裂或解决任何这些遗留的政治纠纷。它应该是那些想要保护这片大陆的人可以团结起来支持的东西，无论他们或他们的国家可能有什么不同的既得利益。所以，虽然它是为南极洲制作的，但他希望人们能继续在世界各地悬挂它，并将其视为一个统一的标志。这有助于每个人对保护这个非常独特的地方变得更加感兴趣和投入。嗯，这是一个非常好的故事，结果是一面非常好的
flag, which is my favorite part of the whole story. Of course, of course. Well, thanks for bringing this to us and, uh, you know, happy fly, Zayn. Yeah, happy fly day to you, T-Roman. T-Roman. 99% of the visible was produced this week by Kurt Colstad and Joe Rosenberg. Music by our director of sound, Sean Rihall. Mixed by Carolina Rodriguez. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Thorez Odin, Vivian Leigh, Chris Barubey, Christopher Johnson, Washington, Cady Mingle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to the day to our translator Magumi Yamamoto as well as Larry Perraak at the Alameda
旗帜，这是我整个故事中最喜欢的部分。当然，当然。好吧，感谢你把它带给我们，呃，你知道，快乐旗帜日。是的，快乐旗帜日，罗曼。罗曼。本周的《99%无形》由库尔特·科尔斯塔德和乔·罗森伯格制作。音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里霍尔创作。由卡罗莱纳·罗德里格斯混音。德莱尼·霍尔是执行制片人，托雷斯·奥丁、薇薇安·李、克里斯·巴鲁比、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、华盛顿、凯蒂·明格尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马斯。特别感谢我们的翻译惠美·山本，以及阿拉米达的拉里·佩拉克
Naval Air Museum and Christopher Harding at the University of Edinburgh, who we spoke with for Joe's story, but whose voice we didn't get to include. His book, A History of Modern Japan in Search of a Nation, provides great context for further understanding the history of the Hinamaru and Good Luck Flags. You'll find a link to that as well as the Alameda at Naval Air Museum and of course the O-Bond Society on our website, 99pi.org. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM Podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California.
海军航空博物馆和爱丁堡大学的克里斯托弗·哈丁，我们为乔的故事采访了他，但我们没能包含他的声音。他的书《现代日本史：寻找一个国家》为进一步理解日之丸和好运旗的历史提供了很好的背景。你可以在我们的网站 99pi.org 上找到该链接，以及阿拉米达海军航空博物馆和当然还有 O-Bond 协会的链接。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
You can find a show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can do it me at Roman Mars from the show at 9-9-PI org or on Instagram and write it too. You can find other shows I love from Stitcher on our website, 9-9-PI dot org, including Science Rules with Bill Nye. It's featured our episode about Vanta Black. So thank you to that team. You wanna listen to any other 99 PI episodes
你可以在 Facebook 上找到节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以通过 9-9-PI org 的节目联系我罗曼·马斯，或者在 Instagram 上写信给我。你可以在我们的网站 9-9-PI dot org 上找到我从 Stitcher 喜欢的其他节目，包括比尔·奈的《科学规则》。它在我们的关于 Vanta Black 的剧集中有专题介绍。所以感谢那个团队。你想听任何其他 99 PI 剧集吗
that you might have missed? Look no further than 99PI.org. With one correction for this episode, it turns out we pronounce the Japanese word obone incorrectly. The entire episode is pronounced obone, not obone. Thank you to our listeners for catching that and pointing out to us. This has been a Stitcher Radio Production, broadcast around the globe by the serious
你可能错过了？看看 99PI.org 就知道了。本集有一个更正，原来我们把日语单词 obone 发音错了。整集都发音为 obone，而不是 obone。感谢我们的听众发现并指出了这一点。这是一部 Stitcher Radio 制作，由 Sirius
XM satellite network. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
XM 卫星网络向全球广播。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。